είχα την προζογήα να συνεχίσω ηλικια κάημουν καλά παρόλο ξατο τελευταίως ναιόληατα κιμουτριατα δύο χρονώ
θέρουσα ότι μο αυτιάξω τοπο ότι μου έχω αλλατρία τέρα χρόνια που θα μπορώ να
εκπρόσωπο ότι χώράν αξιωπρεπές σίγουρα όταν έχι και ένα παιδί να αφήις για κιένα κα
πίσω μόνιτς μένα παιδίαίπρέπει να πάεις πρώτημασίανα λίψει τις καπέντκο ημέρες να έρτις να ξαναθει
σε έναμηνα αγώνες και τιπά ήταν κάπως ξε μεγάε αποφάσει σας φούμε είναι κάναμε νιοικογένειαν
μαζέψουν καιλίοκαι να το μεγαλών το μορώ που δε μου το έκτρασε ποτέ αλλά το
καταλάβενα δεν ήταν και εύκολο και ιαμένα σίγουρα και από ότιγονίς μου που εγώ κο
χρόνωέφυγα ποα ελλάδα και στην ουσια λεγα ότι έδρα μου είναι ελλάδαλλά ήμούν ράτιμου φάκουν
κυρώτην ευρώπουγίο τον κόσμο που είναι καμάμε πολλά χριστούγνα μαζί ομίζω χριστοίναν κνε καιν κπντε
κάξι χρόνια πράγαμε μια φτιο φορές σας πούμε ιτάξει παράποναλλά ήξεραν και ζίνι για πιο
λόγοήταν δίπλαμο εναιαι ότι οκυράκο στηντεθτάι τι κάνι τις ζωή του αχουμε κανες λεφτα από
τον αύρατησμ έκαμαιέκαμα θα μπορεύσ να κάμω πολύ περισσότερα μην ξεχνάσω ότι με τρεις φορές
παγκόσμίος μεταλλίούχος με πολλές επιτυχίες όμως έκαματα χριματα τα οποία μου εξασφάλησαν τουλάχιστον κάποια πράματα
που σίγουρα θα πρέπε να δουλέψουν πολύ σκλια για να ταποκτίσω δούλιψαέχω ισπράξει οκτώ χειρουργία
όποτε ηα νομίζω καταλαμβαίνεις ότι δεν ήταεύκρε δε τερήσει σε σαλικά τοσαουμε τα α ρσω
η υπουργιώ ακρητισμού είναι κάλι το οποίο σίγουρα το μόνο διάστημα θα γίλι θεωρίς ότι
ο πρόεδρος της δημοκρατίας